- You don't know which
officer is going to show up.
You don't know how they're going to react,
you don't know how the script works.
The script is non-existent
for a lot of people
and that's where the problem is.
It's a dice roll a lot of time.
(solemn music)
It's just one of those
moments where like your
mind just starts racing.
How, like, what road is
this going to go down?
I feel like at this point
you just, like, never know.
- May parents, I forget
what they were doing,
but I was standing outside.
I was seven or eight and I
saw the police beat up a man.
I remember not asking my parents about it
because I had the very,
sort of, visceral sense
that this is just how things were.
- I think of all the other people
who were doing nothing wrong.
And still died in a situation.
It's just the fear of
knowing that I can do
a million things that would seem harmless
to me or anybody else.
And that it could end my life.
(sighs)
- When you just look around a realize
that the playing field is not level.
- I definitely struggle
with whether it's even fair
or ethical to bring a
black child into this world
with things being the way that they are.
- With the gamble to live in general,
but I think there's a
big difference between
chance things that can
happen and then that there is
people out here who
will target your child.
- You know, they might be part of this
ongoing theater of violence
without repercussion.
I don't know if I have that in me.
- I can't recall a certain
moment where I was like,
"Oh, you know now this happened and so
now as a result, like I'm scared."
I think just probably
witnessing things over time.
I don't think these are
necessarily new things,
but with technology we just see them
a lot more instantly.
And it's definitely intensified.
- I love to walk late at night,
and while I think to think I present
as pretty unassuming and non-threatening,
there's always a chance that someone
could not see me that way.
- Stay safe but also, like,
don't let it change who you are.
- I don't want them to
make us be afraid to love.
And to have families.
- All cops need to play by the same rules.
And those rules need to be,
that everyone is treated equally.
That's what's at the core of all of this.
(solemn music)